TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, I'm
Timothy Jordan, and welcome
back to "The Developer Show."
Earlier this month,
"Developer Show"
correspondent Dan Galvin headed
to India for Google Developer
Days.
While he was there, he caught
up with some colleagues
to get the latest updates
on TensorFlow, Android,
Android Things, and more.
Full interviews are linked
in the description below.
Here are some of the highlights.
TensorFlow Lite is TensorFlow's
lightweight solution
for mobile and embedded devices.
Anitha Vijayakumar, a technical
program manager on TensorFlow
Lite, answers some common
questions y'all have asked
about doing on-device
machine learning inference.
Android Instant Apps allows
Android users to run your apps
instantly without installation.
Android developer
advocate Lila Fujiwara
described some of the
key elements of turning
your app into an instant app.
Android Things lets you build
professional mass market
products on a trusted platform
without previous knowledge
of embedded system design.
Android Things developer
advocate Wayne Piekarski
shows us an Android
Things developer kit,
describes the developer preview,
and talks about what people
are building with the platform.
Kotlin is now an official
language on Android.
Android developer
advocate Sean McQuillan
gives us some tips on getting
started with Kotlin by using it
for testing and describes
some of the recent Android
updates that make programming
with Kotlin even easier.
Last but not least,
one more interview
from the Android team.
Android developer advocate
Florina Muntenescu
chats with Dan about
architecture components
and an opportunity for
you to provide feedback
on the new paging library.
Find that interview
and all the others
linked in the description below.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you back here
for more of "The
Developer Show" in 2018.
[MUSIC PLAYING]